payback time that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now watching joe biden's plummeting
approval ratings continue to slip it
keeps going down down it's like watching
a game of limbo you keep wondering to
yourself
how low can joe go
a new politico morning console poll
gives us a snapshot in time and it's
ugly for the white house 43 percent
approve now of biden's job performance
53 percent disapprove
now among key demographics he's
underwater women they're running away
from him suburbanites they are too and
independents forget about them look at
those numbers now on the pandemic just
39 approve of the job biden's doing and
57 percent
disapprove
now support for mass mandates vaccine
mandates it's also dropping and
localities across the country are
following suit
so today in the parents rights hot spot
of loudoun county virginia they just
announced that masks would be optional
starting next week now this came just
hours after governor glenn younkin
signed a new law requiring schools to go
mask optional by march 1st
so everywhere you look there are bad
omens for democrats
even their political heavyweights are
feeling the heat
like illinois billionaire governor j.p
pritzker now he was just slapped down by
a bipartisan legislative committee which
voted 9-0 to suspend his emergency
coveted rules
now they obviously saw the writing on
the wall after a state judge had already
granted a tro in favor of parents from a
hundred school districts that oppose
school mass mandates
what's amazing about this though is
pritzker seems totally unfazed he's
still weighing his options
doctors say that masks are the best way
to preserve in-person learning and keep
children and staff safe everyone should
feel comfortable wearing their masks and
either way the next step is to hear from
the appellate court and go from there
next step
perhaps more shocking though is the
realization that even uber left-wing san
franciscans can't they can be pushed too
far outraged parents there successfully
voted to recall three radical school
board members just last night
so the warning signs for the democrats
are flashing red
people want change
the sports and entertainment industry
has moved on as well from the masklas
super bowl to springtime live music
events
two of the most popular festivals
announced today they were ditching all
covet rules no vaccines no masks not
even negative tests are going to be
required for entry good for them
but bad for the democrat party that
banked on these rules to keep them in
power by keeping you scared
yet democrats handling of kovid isn't
the only thing that's dragging him down
politico is reporting tonight that
private polling from the dcc
shows that gop attacks using issues such
as critical race theory defund the
police and open borders or amnesty are
alarmingly potent and if democrats don't
respond to republican attacks on these
issues the gop's lead on the generic
ballot jumps from 4 to 14 points in
swing districts okay let me just say
this 14 points that would mean a
complete wipeout for the democrats in
november
but get ready
i promise you that one by one vulnerable
democrats will attempt to pivot or to
turn the page or reframe the narrative
they're going to say things like
well we were always planning to drop the
masks or we were never really for
defunding the police or we think some
prosecutors are too soft on crime and of
course they're going to say we respect
parents rights to speak out at school
board meetings
i'm telling you tonight believe none of
this they're lying
every key democrat on the hill except
maybe joe manchin and kirsten cinema
they line up with the left on most major
issues
so i don't believe these so-called
moderates who only speak out against the
radicals when they're backed into a
political corner
people like montana's john tester who's
up for re-election this year
the national democratic brand in in in i
think in rural america general is toxic
i honestly don't think the democratic
party can be a majority party unless we
start appealing to middle america a lot
more now what a phony
ditto for so-called moderate mark kelly
in arizona both he and tester are just
as responsible for their parties lurch
to the left as chuck schumer and dick
durbin
like where were they when the school's
issue really blew up
where were they when blm was terrorizing
our cities they
you hear them speak out then i didn't
so this summer when democrats returned
to their home states and they're arguing
that their common sense policies are
what got us through the pandemic and
back to normal life
just laugh in their faces respectfully
of course
they had literally nothing to do with
freeing america we freed ourselves and
you should be proud of that
and be grateful for the leadership of
president trump who knew early on that
we had to reopen and we had to all go
back to work and get back to
normal and what would it would any of us
have done without the republican
governors who fought themselves for the
people
and they thought for themselves they
didn't feel bound by the guidance of
unelected bureaucrats like tony fauci
like trump and they were relentlessly
attacked for it
so this is a time to be proud of who we
are
parents mothers fathers working class
people new citizens of all backgrounds
professionals
we're americans and we know our rights
and we expect results from the people
who swore to uphold the constitution
now we'll give people the benefit of the
doubt for sure but our patience has its
limits
we're not going to be played by
charlatans
so stop insulting our intelligence
we know what you did and we know what
you're planning to do if you really get
a stranglehold on power
and we will stop you at the ballot box
because november is payback time
and that's the angle